parce notre autre sujet celui sur les
écoles salafistes alors c'est une
nouvelle illustration avec ce qu à
echirolles dans la banlieue de grenoble
le ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer veut fermer cette école
primaire hors contrat il explique
pourquoi on va l'écouter tout de suite
c'était le 30 avril dernier sur radio
france france bleu isère pardon nous
considérons qu'il ya une urgence pour
les enfants de ne pas se retrouver
soumis un projet pédagogique qui est
nocif pour eux qui est grave parce que
ça consiste à embrigader des enfants on
voit suffisamment les dégâts que cela
fait dans la société d'avoir des enfants
qui sont élevés dans des idéologies
dangereuses qui vont contre les lois de
la république et c'est tout à fait
normal que la république se donne des
règles pour faire en sorte que tous les
enfants bénéficient d'une instruction
qui soit conforme aux lois tout
simplement comme didier leschi et on a
d'un côté admise l'éducation qui nous
dit cette école il faut la fermer
l'école qui porte plainte on veut peut
le faire en diffamation contre le
ministre à l'imbroglio judiciaire
mais comment résoudre cette quadrature
du cercle fermé des écoles qui
manifestement sont hors des clous et
préserver cette liberté danse d'abord je
pense que me de l'éducation nationale ne
dis pas ça par hasard c'est à dire que
les écoles hors contrat dès lors
qu'elles reçoivent des enfants elles
sont soumises quand même incertaine
rennes est entre autres à la possibilité
d'une inspection c'est qu'il ya eu une
inspection de l'indicé est donc et donc
c'est sur la base du rapport
d'inspection que le ministre de
l'éducation nationale à juste titre à
mon sens si le rapport est avéré alors
la justice peut essayer le trancher mais
il va falloir rentrer dans une expertise
et une contre-expertise si j'ose dire on
y arrive à fermer ses écoles
d'abord d'abord on peut y arriver mais
je crois que le sujet important c'est
que ce type d'école se développent et on
mesure mal la fragmentation scolaire qui
est en train de se construire avec des
opérateurs je pense par exemple à l'ithq
requis en france est en réalité le
premier opérateur en matière d'ouverture
d'école à caractère propre et de collège
et il
fait en exportant les valeurs qui sont
aujourd'hui les siennes en turquie c'est
à dire les valeurs de la cap et et qui
ont des dynamiques qui sont le contraire
de ce qu'on souhaite je rappelle que
dans l'étude qu'on appelle trajectoires
et origines qui est une étude assez
longue
sur ce que deviennent les jeunes et en
particulier les jeunes issus de
l'immigration
la seule communauté où les filles
scolairement réussissent moins que les
garçons ce sont les filles d'origine
turque et c'est directement lié au type
d'éducation et à ce compte là je pense
qu'il est important de contrôler les
écoles qui s'ouvre comme on le fait pour
d'autres c'est à dire que il faut quand
même rappeler que ça se fait pour
d'autres écoles à caractère propre et il
n'y a pas que pour des écoles musulmanes
qu'il ya des contrôles pas que pour les
écoles musulmanes mais c'est pas elle
qui pose quand même
en général le plus de difficultés les
écoles musulmanes les écoles musulmanes
au contrat à elle pose des difficultés
parce que très souvent le corps
enseignant n'a pas conscience qu'il y a
quand même un cadre je rappelle qu'en
france qui est obligatoire c'est
l'instruction l'instruction on peut se
faire au sein de l'école publique dans
une école à caractère propre qui peut
être ou non son contrat et à domicile et
que la volonté de l'état depuis
plusieurs années c'est de contrôler de
plus en plus ce qui se fait à domicile
en envoyant des inspecteurs pour voir si
les personnes les jeunes acquièrent le
minimum qui est imposée à tous les
jeunes quel que soit le lieu de
l'éducation d'instruction et ont sans
cela il faut un contrôle rigoureux parce
que on arrive à une société où dès le
plus jeune âge
la séparation est accentué par des
discours idéologiques qui sont délétères
du point de vue de notre pacte
républicain les alors je lis l'article
didaoui consac ce matin les rapports
d'inspection met en évidence une
suprématie la région sur les sciences
et encore ça doit être dit de façon
assez édulcoré oui ça veut dire qu on
est dans ce qui a été
je me rappelle à l'origine de la crise
des tris successifs du foulard la
première affaire du foulard à creil elle
n'est non pas parce que les jeunes
filles portent le foulard
ce qui dans un premier temps est
acceptée
parce qu'elle refuse les cours de
sciences naturelles et donc on voit bien
que le minimum commun mais plus
enseignée parce que les cours de
sciences naturelles font partie du
programme obligatoire de base
ça veut pas dire que en dehors des cours
il n'est pas la possibilité d'avoir un
discours religieux
le problème c'est quand le discours
religieux se mélange au disco
enseignement général là on est dans
autre chose et ils sont nés plus
exactement dans le caractère propre tel
qu'il peut exister par exemple dans
d'autres pour d'autres écoles jacky
isabello les des élus ont été trop ou
trop fermé les yeux sur ces ouvertures
d'écoles
si j'ai correctement votre papier je
crois qu'il est fait mention d'une
nouvelle loi la ligue est elle qui a été
prise en 2018 et cette école date
d'avant 2018 dire qu' on ne peut pas lui
appliquer ces nouveaux principes qui
réglemente beaucoup plus qu'ils
financent donc qu'il ouvre l'école qui
la dirigent et qui pratique
l'enseignement et avec ces nouveaux
critères
on pourrait éviter tous ces travers de
dévoiement de de l'enseignement mais ce
que vous dites est très important parce
qu'on l'a complètement oublié moi j'ai
toujours été stupéfait lorsque j'ai
découvert que rené rémond était
favorable au maintien du foulard chargé
par le général de gaulle d'une mission
de laïcité quand on m'a dit mais rené
rémond et est contre l'interdiction du
voile
je me suis dit j'ai loupé quelque chose
donc pompidou en moi c'est pareil voyez
donc
il est trés il est très vieux jeu le
pauvre parce qu'il est plus de ce monde
et je me suis dit j'ai loupé quelque
chose et quand vous rappeler que à
l'origine de cette grande querelle
c'était la remise en question n'ont pas
de cet attribut mais des des conclusions
section s'est assurée le tout de suite
ça reprend un peu plus de on retrouve
les fondements de de la séparation des
communautés et des conflits qui se
sentent qu'ils se sont qui ont qui sont
engendrées par la suite alexis le
célèbre blanquer rire c'est courageux
parce que c'est vrai que c'est difficile
c'est vrai qu'il faut le faut le faire
il le fait alors après heureusement il
ya des lois il ya un droit et et les
écoles qui sont fermés bons peuvent dire
sont déjà fermés sur un mauvais
fondement un fondement injuste et leur
laisser le jeu enfin bon pour l'instant
et 2017 l'inspection et la fermeture
elle a été maintenue
oui dans les jours c'est pour ça que
j'accepte ces courageux et que s'il y en
a sans doute bien d'autres qui auraient
fermé et c'est encore aussi vrai sont
plus vrai pour un centre de mosquées et
là on voit combien c'est difficile parce
que paraît il ya le chaque fois qu'une
décision est prise par un préfet de
fermer parce que ou d'expulser un imam
qui aurait tenu des discours extrémistes
c est bien il ya un recours et ceci est
le concentré de l'administratif et de
conseil d'état il revient et c'est
extrêmement difficile juridiquement donc
je veux dire raison de plus pour saluer
le courage de blanc caire de tenter le
coup je pense que c'est pas plus vrai
comme vous dites pour les mosquées mais
moins vrai pour les mosquées je
m'explique
c'est d'abord c'est un sujet très
important et très difficile parce que
c'est quand même le sujet de savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on tolère qu'est-ce qu'on
interdit et comme nous sommes dans une
société de liberté il faut y aller
doucement sur ce qu'on interdit
deuxièmement je pense que tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire interdire l appel
à l appel au terrorisme et c'est tout le
monde est d'accord en france aux états
unis par exemple ce serait pas le cas en
france on a une consommation
relativement stricte de la liberté qui
est au delà de ça quand il ya incitation
à la haine
acial notamment un truc on peut
interdire d'accord et ça ça vaut aussi
bien pour les mosquées que pour les
écoles mais après quand il s'agit pas
d'appel à la haine raciale ou à la
discrimination mais qu'il s'agit d'un
discours religieux traditionalistes
moi je ne connais pas le dossier donc je
ne sais pas si cette histoire religion
et science
c'était quelqu'un qui disait la religion
c'est plus important que la science ou
si c'est quelqu'un qui disait la science
de vous dire des bêtises c'est ce que
dit la religion qui est juste c'est
quand même pas du tout la même chose
je n'ai pas de dossier puisqu'on n'est
pas le lot si ce que je sais c'est que
cette question de l'interdiction d'un
discours que ce soit salafistes
rigoureux s'il n'a rien à voir et le
terrorisme que ce soit juif
traditionalistes que ce soit catholique
saint nicolas du chardonnet
je trouve que il faut y aller avec des
pincettes et avec des critères et
maintenant c'est là où j'en viens à
votre mot plus pour les mosquées de dix
mois pour les mosquées je pense qu'il
est légitime que les critères pour
l'école soit lui soit lu strict que les
critères pour la mosquée dire que dans
un cas ni mam presse une conception
rigoriste de l'imam de deux adultes et
républicains lui s'il n'ya aucun rapport
avec la pelle au terrorisme je pense que
c'est difficile dans toute liberté de
l'interdire en revanche l'école c'est
pas pareil c'est que vous avez vous avez
raison sur la nécessaire sévérité pour
l'école à mes yeux mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que pour les musulmans
tout ça forme un tout il n'ya pas nous
on dit il ya les lois civiles et les
lois religieuses
il ya ce qu'on dit à l'école via ce
qu'on dit la mosquée mais c'est un
système qui englobe tout c'est à dire
que ces enfants on leur parle pas que de
la science on leur apprend sept heures
par semaine qu'il faut couper la main
des voleurs qu'il faut lapider les
femmes adultères qu'il faut trucider les
homosexuels et que les mécréants
méritent tous de montréal je suis pas la
culotte et bien sûr passer le cap et
shiloh mais bon c'est normal
c'est le catéchisme normal parce que
vous avez énormément musulmans et
d'imams qui n'apprennent absolument pas
ça vous vous avez une vision totalement
caricatural à celle des musulmans sont
des extrémistes
c'est un lieu qui on sait que ça mais
c'est fou mais c'est faux voudrait
abriter les riman qui disent que moi je
faisais ce que je suis d'accord et vous
la majorité du monde musulman en france
ouais une majorité paisible heureusement
heureusement bien sûr mais elle a la
vida blue moon pour ce discours
la question c'est de savoir pourquoi
c'est le poids de l'extrémisme et ben
monde est d'accord là non c'est pas tout
ce qui va j'ai jamais dit mais bien
faire garder le rapport de la non
voilées veulent faire attention parce
que parce que je le remets ça je vous
rappelle quand même qu'en france il ya
déjà des écoles musulmanes sous contrat
c'est à dire qu'elles ont passé tous les
états qui par ailleurs sont elles mêmes
au centre de quand même pas mal de
polémiques parce qu'on s'est rendu
compte après coup que certains avaient
avec non agréés et que c'était beaucoup
plus compliqué que ce qu'on disait quand
on regarde et notamment les connexions
écouter des responsables de ces cols
axemble responsable frères musulmans
frères musulmans et compagnie parce
qu'il ya ça aussi dessous et éric houde
au sein de certaines je pense que ça ira
contrôle qui est fait par l'éducation
nationale sur ces écoles sont pas très
nombreuses et on a moins d'une dizaine
et à des collèges les résultats
scolaires sont bons ce qui est un clin
d'oeil ce qui est un critère il y à un
contrôle du contenu et je crois qu'il
faut effectivement ne pas mélanger cette
volonté qu'on peut interroger par
ailleurs mais qui vrai pour différentes
différentes catégories de la population
qui est d'aller absolument dans des
écoles à caractère propre parce qu'on
aime défiance vis-à-vis de
l'enseignement public en particulier
dans le collège c'est ça qu'il faut
qu'ils interrogent et du ce point de vue
là il faudrait prendre le problème à
l'envers c'est à dire que essayer de
savoir de comprendre pourquoi ses
parents envoient les enfants dans ce
type d'école il ya sans doute une
inspiration religieuse milhas très
faisant il ya plus de dix ans david
public est dans quelque chose à
reconstruire est ce qu'on peut dire avec
monsieur blanc caire c'est quand des
sacs de reconstruire cette confiance des
ligues l'école publique est le seul
moyen de retrouver une sorte de mélange
républicains au centre du public comme
moi je m'en passe noms des jeunes des
crises à vélo on arrête sur ce sujet